quantum computing
could change everything and it could
represent a fundamental change from the
way we process information today
plus it could enable us to understand
our world
in new and different ways potentially
solving previously intractable problems
so think about the implications right
experts are already looking into ways
quantum computing could be used in areas
like
financial services chemistry artificial
intelligence
and like so many recent advancements in
technology
quantum computers could change how we
approach cyber security
we're considering how quantum could
disrupt the very basis of today's
encryption
methods and impact cryptography
standards
and i know it can be pretty easy to
think i've got plenty of time quantum
computing is years from maturation but
that's only partially true yes quantum
computers are in the early stages of
development but
the reality is the time to prepare was
yesterday
because encrypted data stolen today
could eventually be in the hands of
cyber attackers wielding more advanced
quantum computers tomorrow
but fortunately there's help researchers
are now
developing alternative methods designed
to protect data
as quantum computing progresses and
these new methods could
really change the way we think about and
approach cyber security
we're gaining these new understandings
of how to apply
quantum safe cryptography to help
protect systems and data against current
and future attacks
it's honestly never too early to prepare
companies today
can start building an understanding of
the potential impact to their sensitive
data
and they can educate their security
teams on quantum computing and quantum
safe cryptography
so now is the time to start making your
security strategy
quantum ready
you